a popular tourist destination could
become the first major city in the world
to run out of water officials in Cape
Town South Africa say it's just 92 days
away from having to shut off most water
taps because of a severe drought they
are calling April 21st day 0 Debora
patta is at one of Cape Town's dams
where water levels are dangerously low
Debora good morning good morning
normally I would be completely
underwater standing here but if you look
back you can see the dam levels are
critically no sitting at less than 20%
and this is one of Karen's main sources
of water a source that could run
completely dry within a matter of weeks
surrounded by beautiful stretches of
ocean it's hard to believe Cape Town
could become the first major city in the
world to run out of water only use the
daily allocated amount per person per
day ominously named day zero April 21st
is when the taps will be turned off
three years of successive draft have
devastated the city's water supplies the
local government has brought in severe
restrictions forcing people to look for
alternative supplies like this natural
spring tapped for public use
dramatically you know but I mean it's
also a listen to us not to waste water
they have already been scuffles yes
security guards now monitor the site to
prevent violence from breaking out any
major no wood I will it be chaos it's
gonna be terrible and we're not looking
forward to that time Cape Town's 4
million residents are now only allowed
23 gallons of water per person per day
next month that goes down to 13 gallons
compare that to the average American who
uses around 100 gallons daily 13 gallons
doesn't allow for much a 90 second
shower a quick toilet flash basic
dishwashing weekly laundry and a large
bottle of drinking water outside the
city center the effects of the water
crisis are more obvious
farmer and responder Paul has only been
able to plant a quarter of his corn crop
this year
if the taps are switched off he is
facing financial run it's a desperate
situation you know it's it's a difficult
difficult situation for us is what your
brushing your teeth climate scientist
Peter Johnston says that even if there
is a good rainfall this year the crisis
will not be over Cape Town is getting
hotter that increased temperature is
going to increase evaporation increased
evaporation is going to mean that
there's less water that's available for
our use and that is bad news for a city
that is also a global tourist attraction
welcoming 2 million visitors a year city
officials believe that if kept onehans
drastically cut back their water usage
they could avoid the taps running dry
until the beginning of the rainy season
in May and then the hope is those rains
pour down filling this dam to its
maximum capacity once again Gail or
Debra thank you you put in perspective
13 gallons compared to most Americans
100 gallons makes you think about how
much water you use Thank You Debra
powder in Cape Town